mes chers compatriotes j'ai souhaité
aujourd'hui m'adresser à vous dans moins
d'un an a lieu l'élection
présidentielle la France a rendez-vous
avec la démocratie c'est-à-dire avec
elle-même notre pays subit de grands
désordres desés ordres économique des
ordres budgétaires des ordres social
tout cela entraînant d'autres désordres
dans la vie de chacun et dans les lieux
de vie l'école l'hôpital les quartiers
les zones rurales un pouvoir enfermé
dans ses certitudes a voulu toucher à
tout mais n'a rien réglé je le dit comme
je le pense on ne peut pas innover créer
soigner éduquer et soumettre ses
nécessités vitales aux seules loi du
marché on ne peut pas critiqu iqu à
juste titre le pouvoir financier tout en
le laissant continuer ces pratiques
détestables on ne peut pas protéger les
Français en les livrant ou en leur
imposant les recettes libérales qui les
fragilisent on ne gouverne pas en en
opposant les Français entre
eux les chômeurs et les travailleurs les
jeunes et les plus anciens les Français
et les étrangers on ne préside pas la
France j'en suis convaincu sans porter
haut ses valeurs et son identité qui ont
fait il faut le dire l'admiration du
monde entier derrière l'apparence de
l'énergie aujourd'hui qui d'ailleurs se
confond parfois avec de l'agitation le
pouvoir a surtout une réalité une
politique injuste exclusivement mené au
profit des plus
privilégiés il est temps il est grand
temps que cela change que cela change
réellement et je veux rendre à la France
sa force sa sérénité son unité je veux
redonner à chacun le goût de l'avenir et
l'envie d'un destin en commun c'est cela
l'identité de la France aussi j'ai
décidé de proposer ma candidature à
l'élection
présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
oui vousous le savons la France connaît
des heures difficiles mais je suis
résolu à me battre de toutes mes forces
pour lui redonner
un avenir je crois qu'il n'y a pas de
plus beaux combats qu'il n'y a pas non
plus de mission plus nobl j'ai la
conviction que face au défi du monde et
ils sont nombreux une vision claire une
action cohérente et un langage de vérité
doit permettre de rétablir la confiance
et on en a vraiment besoin de redresser
notre pays et de le rassembler dans la
justice la peur le repli sur soi
le défettisme ce n'est pas la France je
le dis ici dans ma ville de Lille
capitale d'une région industrielle où
rien n'a jamais été donné où tout a
toujours été conquis par le courage et
par le travail des femmes et des hommes
lî cette terre d'hospitalité pour ce
venu d'ailleurs qui font
aujourd'hui contribuer à notre
prospérité lîle vous le savez que j'aime
tant qui m'a tant donné et qui m'a tant
appris je vous le dis aussi en
m'appuyant sur ce que j'ai de plus cher
les valeurs que m'ont transmis ma
famille ces valeurs c'est la morale le
sens de la justice le goût des autres et
le courage et puis je je puise ma force
dans mes convictions de toujours qui
sont celles de la République et de la
gauche
pour moi en effet la liberté rime avec
l'égalité pour donner à chacun les
moyens de construire véritablement sa
vie pour moi seule la fraternité peut
permettre à une société de retrouver de
l'apaisement et de la sérénité pour que
chacun puisse donner le meilleur de
lui-même aux autres pour moi la laïcité
est une valeur inestimable que nous
devons protéger
précieusement
et je le dis aussi après 3 années passé
à la tête du Parti socialiste parce que
je suis confiante dans le projet du
changement que nous avons préparé tous
ensemble pour améliorer la l'état de
notre pays pour répondre aux attentes
des Français et pour tout simplement
redresser la France pendant ces 3 années
et ici dans ma ville et ailleurs j'ai vu
j'ai entendu j'ai écouté j'ai échangé
avec beaucoup d'entre vous j'ai compris
où sont les difficultés chaque Français
les connaît j'ai vu le désarroi et la
colère mais j'ai aussi vu derrière cela
une profonde envie un désir d'agir pour
qu'effectivement partout en France les
choses changent et ce désir croyez-le il
est puissant et c'est vous les Français
qui le portez et pourtant nul nignore la
situation de la France comme d'ailleurs
la gravité de la crise que nous
traversons nous nous aurons et nous le
savons des efforts à réaliser et je
voudrais ici dire les choses fortement
je m'y engage il seront ces efforts
justement répartis on ne peut pas
continuer à demander toujours plus à
ceux qui ont peu et à donner toujours à
ceux qui ont déjà temps tout cela il
faut s'y engager c'est cela aussi ma
conception de la politique et je
voudrais le dire aussi de la même
manière tout ne pourra pas évidemment
être ble tout de suite mais nous
reprendrons ensemble le chemin du
progrès le chemin que la France n'aurait
jamais dû
abandonner je m'adresse à vous français
pour vous dire d'abord que je veux
relever le défi d'une France qui soit à
la fois innovante compétitive et
écologique nous avons des ressources
puissantes qui nous permettent de
retrouver ou d'être dans le Poton de
tête des nations nos ouvriers nos
employés nos cadres nos agriculteurs nos
entreprises nos chercheurs nos créateurs
nos artistes ils déborde de compéten
d'imagination et d'initiative encore
faut-il les accompagner par une
politique fortees de l'État et des
collectivités locales renforcé nos
jeunes sont énergiques et créatifs il
faut leur faire confiance et il faut
leur donner les moyens de leur autonomie
nous avons le dit tous les atouts pour
réussir dans la compétition mondiale en
bâtissant dans une France conquérante un
nouveau modèle économique social et
écologique qui pourra donner à notre
pays une génération d'avance c'est cela
aussi le défi auquel je vous
convie je veux aussi
restaurer la justice la justice associée
à la promesse républicaine les Français
doivent pouvoir vivre de leur travail
avec des emplois qui les valorisent avec
des emplois qui leur permettent de
progresser les jeunes doivent pouvoir
construire leur vie faire des projets
pour leur travail mais aussi pour leur
vie tout simplement les parents doivent
pouvoir éduquer et protéger leurs
enfants chacun doit avoir accès aux
soins et au logement un logement digne
nos anciens nos anciens ont le droit à
une retraite décente et à une prise en
charge de la perte d'autonomie par la
solidarité nationale la sécurité qui est
pour nous un droit essentiel doit être
assuré je le redis je l'ai souvent dit
mais le gouvernement utilise
l'insécurité pour faire peur moi je veux
la combattre véritablement et
réellement pour faire cela pour
restaurer cette promesse républicaine
nous nous appuierons principalement et
pas seulement principalement sur des
services publics qui seront rénovés et
attentifs à chacun mais aussi sur une
fiscalité redevenue juste car c'est cela
aussi le fondement d'une république mais
je vous promets aussi de nouvelles
conquêtes de nouvelles conquêtes comme
par exemple l'égalité des droits comme
nous voulons que cette égalité devienne
enfin une réalité et bien sûr je pense
d'abord à l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes notamment dans le domaine
salarial je voudrais aussi que la
culture soit mise à l'avant la culture à
l'avant c'est quoi c'est simplement nous
inspirer nous faire grandir nous
réunir
enfin je veux que notre pays retrouve
toute sa voix dans le
monde la France notre France avec une
diplomatie et une défense qui sera
respectée doit œuvrer pour la paix pour
la démocratie et pour la prospérité du
monde sa voix doit à nouveau être
entendue pour un autre équilibre du
monde et pour accompagner les mouvements
de ceux qui se battent pour la liberté
et la démocratie et bien sûr elle doit
aussi se battre pour l'Europe vous le
savez c'est presque dans mes gênnes
l'Europe est pour moi un combat de
toujours mais je veux une nouvelle
Europe une Europe qui produise mais
aussi qui protège une Europe qui fasse
respecter des nouvelles règles dans le
commerce international une Europe forte
mais qui soit en même temps solidaire
il nous faut donc redonner à la France
son poids et sa voix il nous faut la
rassembler dans la justice mais cela ne
se fera pas sans un grand souffle
démocratique dont notre pays a tant
besoin il faudra une présidente qui
préside un gouvernement qui gouverne un
parlement qui soit renforcé et
respecté des organisations syndicales et
des associations qui soient au cœur du
change
une indépendance pour la justice et pour
les médias qui soit totalement restaurée
et puis bien sûr une nouvelle
décentralisation qui soit à la fois
réelle et démocratique oui je le dis
simplement là aussi et fortement il nous
faut oser la démocratie jusqu'au bout
comme nous le faisons avec nos primaires
citoyennes mes chers
compatriotes de la métropole et des
outrmers nous rêvons je crois une grande
majorité d'entre nous peut-être beaucoup
plus nous rêvons d'un vrai changement au
profit de tous un changement dont les
mots se transformment en acte et je suis
enthousiaste à l'idée d'aller à votre
rencontre pour continuer à proposer à
échanger et à construire déjà notre
avenir je veux plus que tout
rassembler vous le savez le
rassemblement c'est pour moi une
doctrine une condition du succès partout
je veux rassembler aujourd'hui les
femmes et les hommes de gauche les
écologistes les humanistes pour qu'en
2012 demain nous puissions rassembler
les Français et la Nation toute
entière avec votre soutien avec votre
confiance je prends aujourd'hui devant
vous l'engagement de la victoire en 2012
vive la République vive la France
[Applaudissements]